معنى الالم من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه العميد
الياس
بيان الجيش وكذلك خوات الدعم السريع الجيش
يقول بان الاوضاع مستقره وبانه دمر اكثر
من خمسين بالمئه من قدرات الدرع السريع
برايك في اليوم السابع عشر من هذا
الاشتباك من هذه المواجهات اين هي بوصله
السودان
ايمان لا يمكن معرفه او التحقق من الارقام
اذا كانت 50% او 45% لانه اليوم الحمله
الاعلاميه بالحرب بالقرن ال 21 هي جزء
اساسي من هذه الاعلام والا ما معنى الحرب
للسيطره على الاذاعه السودانيه بام درمان
نحن بمرحله
ليس هناك من معلومات دقيقه على الارض تقول
من يربح ومن يخسر لانه قياس النجاح او
قياس النصر في هذه المعركه لا تزال الحرب
في حول القصر الجمهوري القياده العامه
المطار اندرمان
خرطوم بحري المنطقه الصناعيه وحتى في
دارفور فاذا نحن امام مرحله ضبابيه
والحمله الاعلاميه هي جزء اساسي من هذه
الحرب يعني في ظل هذه المرحله الضبابيه
ونحن نعود واكرر في هذا اليوم السابع عشر
من هذه الحرب من هذه الاشتباك كيف يمكن
تفسير استمرار هذه الاشتباكات رغم كل
الهدن المعلنه وهذه الهدنه السادسه التي
وصلنا اليها اليوم هذا النشاط الميداني
الهدى سادس هدنه تخدم الفريقين وبالتالي
اغلب هذه الهدن هي مفروضه ومطلوبه من
الخارج لاخلاء الرعايه ونعرف الحركه
الناشطه في بورتسودان فاذا اليوم في هذه
المرحله هي تناسب الطرفين ولكن اليوم حتى
الان لم يحقق شيء على الارض يعني لم ينتصر
فريق على الاخر واذا اعتبرنا ان هناك
ثلاثه سيناريوات الحسم السريع هذا امر ليس
متوفر حاليا
الذهاب الى طاوله المفاوضات لم يتحقق شيء
على الارض للذهاب الى طاوله المفاوضات
ولكن يبقى السيناريو الثالث وهو الاسوا
على المدى البعيد استمرار
الاشتباكات
خروج البعثات والاجانب من السودان انتقال
الاشتباكات من العاصمه الى الاطراف وهذا
هو السيناريو الكارثي
السيناريوهات يعني كيف يمكن ان
نتوقع استراتيجيه الجيش الان وانطلاقا من
هذا البيان اليوم الذي اصدره الجيش
استراتيجيه في المرحله المقبله
الجيش كي ينتصر يجب ان يتبع الاسلوب اللين
يعني استعمال تكتيكات مختلفه يعني لدى
الجيش قوات خاصه خمس سرايا معدل 200 جندي
من السرايا له الغزاره الناريه له القوه
الصلبه له الطيران وبالتالي اليوم تدور
المعارك منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اسابيع على
القصر الجمهوري على المطار وحتى على
القياده العامه بالمطلق وبالمعنى العسكري
وعلى الورق يجب ان يكون هذا الامر قد
انتهى منذ بدايات الحرب فاس يجب ان يكون
هناك تكتيك مختلف وليس القتال عن بعد كما
يحصل الان اشكرك الياس حنان الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه كنت معنا من بيروت